Let's try another problem Lucy and Javier can mow their lawn in 1.2 hours time
if they work together. If it takes Javier one hour longer than Lucy, how long
would it take them to mow the yard alone? Now, we want to use our same approach
from before. We're going to use our 1 over a plus 1 over b equals 1 over x.
Where x is the total amount of time it takes them to do a job together. We know
that total time is 1.2 hours. So we can replace x with 1.2. Now we don't know
how long it took Javier or how long it took Lucy. Those are both unknowns. So
what do you think we could write here and here, in order to finish out our
equation? You'll need to think about how Lucy's time to mow the yard and how
Javier's time to mow the yard alone relate to one another. When you think you
know what should go in this denominator, and what should go in this
denominator, type them in here. As a hint, you'll have to use a variable, and
for this one I want you to use the variable t.